well that's commissioning right I think
he's off to a good start in that regard
he's certainly reaching out and opening
up the American brand if you will in a
way that the previous administration was
not particularly nimble with and that
will be a very very good thing I was I
was encouraged by the fact that you know
this g20 was radically different from
the the the meeting similar to it back
into the early 1930s that I think it was
the first time the FDR administration
got involved and actually ended up
resulting in a lot more protectionism
around the world so you know there's
certainly some levels of heightened
protectors protectionism happening but
but clearly it's it's not nearly as bad
as many feared and hopefully it will not
get any worse than might get a little
better you know coming from Forbes you
know we're free market capitalist I
firmly believe in that I think history
has shown that's you know that's a
really good way to go out there and rise
the overall quality of living for all
involved so I'm very very hopeful that
in fact we won't see barriers being
built up and we still will see the free
flow of capital and free flow of ideas
around the globe and you know it's even
more important now because it's been you
know repeated ad nauseam it's a much
smaller globe it's a much more
interconnected world and if you think
about it we only have to look at the
initiation of this recession to have a
recent example of that you know the
world went bad in the US and within
weeks or months it went bad around the
world
well it's this concept of brand America
that was sort of begin to be banter to
blackest has always been talked about
but was sort of his conscious level was
was increased probably bout the halfway
through the second term of the Bush
administration with a notion at the
American brand brand America was under
duress and it was there was a lot of
ill-will towards the administration
there was a lot of go it alone thought
and not a lot of outreach and discussion
around that thought so even things that
we probably should have done we could
have been better about explaining or you
know giving a you know a sugary concept
as opposed to simply handing it down so
I think you know where the Obama
administration has been alone it's very
very early yet but certainly where
they've suggested they're going to be in
when they've been so far is trying to be
much more communicative and much more
open to ideas from around the globe